.
PLAN B.
>> FOR ANOTHER TIME, I THINK.
>> FOR ANOTHER TIME?
ALL RIGHT.
>> Judge Jeanine: THEY ARE
LOSING IT OVER THE OFFER.
A WASHINGTON POST: MISSING THIS
"I AM FRIGHTENED BY THE IMPACT
ON SOCIETY AND POLITICS IF
ELON MUSK ACQUIRES TWITTER.
HE SEEMS TO BELIEVE ON
SOCIAL MEDIA, ANYTHING GOES PURE
DEMOCRACY TO SURVIVE.
WE NEED MORE CONTENT MODERATION,
NOT LESS.
ALL RIGHT, DANA, I'M GOING TO
START WITH YOU.
OKAY, SO ZUCKERBERG SAYS THIS IS
NOT ABOUT MONEY.
HE BELIEVES TWITTER SHOULD BE
THE OPEN MARKET SQUARE AND OPEN
SOURCE.
HE SAYS IT IS IMPORTANT,
LITERALLY, TO THE FUTURE OF
CIVILIZATION.
>> Dana: ELON MUSK NOT
MARK ZUCKERBERG ALTHOUGH HE
MIGHT AGREE.
>> Judge Jeanine:
MARK ZUCKERBERG WHO DOESN'T
AGREE.
>> Dana: I DO LOVE THE
MELTDOWN OF EVERYBODY.
IT IS INTERESTING TO ME FOR SO
MANY YEARS OF THE LIBERALS AND
THEY HAD A GOOD POINT, THEY SAID
THEY WERE FOR FREE SPEECH AND
CONSERVATIVES WERE NOT BUT NOW
EVERYTHING IS FLIPPED AROUND AND
NOW ALL OF A SUDDEN WE SHOULD
ALLOW MORE SPEECH AND ALLOW
EVERYBODY TO BE ON THE PLATFORM
AND ARE THINKING, NO, WE NEED
MORE CONTROL.
AND I THINK IT IS REALLY FUNNY
THAT SO MANY PEOPLE BELIEVE THAT
THE GOVERNMENT COULD DO THIS
BETTER THAN THE PRIVATE SECTOR
PEER THAT WILL NOT ACTUALLY
HAPPEN.
I'VE NEVER -- I GUESS, THE FIRST
HOSTILE TAKEOVER THAT I'VE
REALLY BEEN INTERESTED IN AND
WATCH CLOSELY.
I DON'T KNOW EXACTLY WHAT WILL
HAPPEN BUT I THINK IT IS
INTERESTING AND I WISH I COULD
BE A FLY ON THE WALL AS
EMPLOYEES ARE MEETING BECAUSE
THEY HAD TO HAVE A DAY OF REST
BECAUSE ELON MUSK MIGHT HAVE
TAKEN A BOARD SEAT AND HE
DIDN'T.
I DON'T KNOW THAT THE VACATION
SITUATION THEY WILL HAVE AFTER
TODAY'S MEETING.
>> Judge Jeanine: YOU KNOW,
MUSK DID TAKE A SHOT
MARK ZUCKERBERG WHEN ASKED ABOUT
SPEECH PLATFORMS LIKE TWITTER
BEING CONTROLLED BY ONE PERSON.
THEN THEY MADE THE REFERENCE TO
ZUCKERBERG AND FACEBOOK AND THEN
INSTAGRAM.
SO AN WHATSAPP.
IT SEEMS LIKE MUSK HAS IT IN FOR
ZUCKERBERG AND HE IS NOT HAPPY
WITH WHAT ZUCKERBERG DID.
>> Greg: I DON'T CARE ABOUT
THAT MUCH.
I'M INTERESTED IN THIS NEW
PHRASE CONTENT MODERATION
BECAUSE IT SOUNDS REALLY GOOD.
WE MODERATE CONTENT HERE ALL THE
TIME.
>> Judge Jeanine: COME ON.
>> Greg: THEN IT ALL GOES TO
HELP YOU WRITE ABOUT EUPHEMISM
FOR CENSORSHIP.
THE THING IS, WHAT SCARES BECKS
BONE AND CNN IS THE FACT THAT
THEY MIGHT HAVE TO PRESENT THE
OTHER SIDE TO THEIR PERSPECTIVER
THAT IS TWICE THE WORK.
THEY DON'T WANT TO DO IT.
YOU TALK ABOUT ELON MUSK AND
BURY SOMETHING LIKE A LAPTOP, HE
WILL UNHURT THE OTHER POTENTIAL
COUNTERPOINT SPIRIT ABOUT WHAT
YOU SAID, HOSTILE TAKEOVER, IT
IS ACTUALLY.
HE IS UNDERTAKING -- YOU KNOW
WHAT MAKES HIM AN AMERICAN AND
GLOBAL TREASURE?
HE IS UNDERTAKING A HOSTILE
TAKEOVER OF A DRUG CARTEL
BECAUSE TWITTER IS THE DRUG THAT
ALL JOURNALISTS ARE ADDICTED TO,
RIGHT?
THE DRUG IS MANIPULATING
STORIES, NARRATIVES TO CREATE
THIS CONTENT AND DIVISION.
AND THEY CAN'T GET ENOUGH OF IT.
THAT IS WHY THEY ARE SO UPSET
BECAUSE THEY WILL LOSE THIS
DRUG.
NOW, HE MIGHT BE IN CHARGE OF
THE DISTRIBUTION OF THE
NARCOTIC.
YOU HAVE TO WONDER, WILL THE
PRESS WITH THE DRUG WITHOUT
SELLING IT?
I DON'T THINK SO.
THIS IS WHY THE PURCHASE -- WE
WERE TALKING THE OTHER DAY IT IS
MORE IMPORTANT THAN FOR THE
PURCHASE "WASHINGTON POST" OR BY
CNN WHICH NO ONE WILL OR ANY
OTHER OUTLET, TWITTER IS ABOVE
THAT.
THEY ARE THE STREAM GNOMIC
STRING THAT CONTROLS THE
PUPPETS.
TWITTER MIGHT NOT BE BIGGER THAN
FACEBOOK OR INSTAGRAM BUT IT
CONTROLS THE PEOPLE YOU WANT TO
CONTROL.
IT CONTROLS THE MEDIA PUPPETRY.
POSSIBLY THE PUPPET MASTER CAN
DECIDE HOW TO THICK GNOMIC FIX
THINGS AND THE FIRST THING TO
CANCEL BY INCREASING MORE
COUNTER NARRATIVES FOR THAT.
>> Judge Jeanine: OKAY, BRIAN,
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" SAID THEY
ARE SO UPSET AT TWITTER THAT
THEY ARE WEIGHING A POISON PILL
WHICH IS SELLING TRADITIONAL
SHARES AT A DISCOUNT SO THAT
PEOPLE CAN GET A BIGGER
PERCENTAGE OF THE COMPANY.
AND I MEAN REALLY UPSET ABOUT
THIS.
>> Brian: WHAT HAPPENED OVER
THE WEEKEND BETWEEN MUSK IS
UNBELIEVABLE.
WHAT HAPPENED, ALSO FOR THE
RECORD OF MY DO CALL FOR A DAY
OF REST.
I ASK MYSELF, WHY DID I DO THAT
SHOW?
A COUPLE OF THINGS COME TO MIND.
I THINK I LOVE YOU WATCH THINGS
HAPPEN AT WASHINGTON CAMINO BUT
THEY WILL DO.
YOU SEE THIS GAME PLAYED OUT.
WE TAKE OUR SIDES AND WE STAND
WHERE WE STAND.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT ELON MUSK IS
GOING TO DO.
IT IS SO GOOD TO SEE SOMEBODY
THAT IS AHEAD OF EVERYBODY.
I'M WILLING TO SAY, SO MUCH MORE
THAN ME, SO MUCH MORE -- I'M
GOING HE IS OUR EDISON KHMER
THOMAS EDISON OR DA VINCI.
SO LET THEM GO.
I DO BELIEVE HE HAS A PLAN B
WHICH WE HAVEN'T DISCUSSED, BUT
WHEN HE GOT STARTED LINT AND PUT
IT IN UKRAINE AND AFFECTED THE
OUTCOME OF A WAR, HE SAID "I
HAVE ALL THE MONEY IN THE WORLD
AND ALREADY MAKING A DIFFERENCE
IN SPACE AND ELECTRIC CARS, I
BELIEVE I CAN CHANGE
FREE SPEECH, NOT DRUM, NOT BIDEN
BUT FOR THE COUNTRY."
THAT IS WHAT IS ABOUT.
I BELIEVE THAT IS THE BIG
PICTURE.
>> Judge Jeanine: HE IS ABOUT
CREATING A BLUEPRINT AND NOT
CREATING ONE.
IN THAT REGARD, WHAT ABOUT THE
TESLA SHAREHOLDERS?
ARE THEY SAYING THEIR GUY IS
GETTING INVOLVED ULTIMATELY AND
POLITICS AND FREE SPEECH IS THE
FIRST AMENDMENT AND I WILL LET
EVERYBODY TALK.
THAT MEANS THE LEFT IS COMING
AFTER YOU.
>> IS AN INTERESTING FIVE PEOPLE
AT THIS TABLE IS ALL FANS OF
ELON MUSK.
>> Judge Jeanine: I AM.
>> LOOK AT THE SCOPE OF IDEOLOGY
AND PHILOSOPHY THAT ENTAILS.
SO THE GOOD NEWS FROM THE POINT
OF VIEW HE VALUES THE COMPANY
OVER $40 BILLION AND SO
EVERYBODY WILL GET RICH BUT THE
BAD NEWS IS HE SAYS THAT IT
NEEDS TO BE TRANSFORMED.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT NEEDS TO BE
TRANSFORMED EXCEPT THAT WHEN
TRUMP GOT THROWN OFF MY LOST
50,000 FOLLOWERS.
HOW DOES THAT HAPPEN?
SO ADD GERALDO RIVERA, BY THE
WAY.
[LAUGHTER]
BUT LISTEN, I TRUST ELON MUSK.
I TRUST HIM.
MECH.
>> Judge Jeanine: EVERYONE OF
US DO.
>> Greg: GNOMIC >> Geraldo:
I TRUST HIM TO BE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
HE BLEW UP THE SPEECH,
BARACK OBAMA, THESE GUYS DON'T
TWEET.
THE BIGGEST USERS ARE USING IT.
>> Greg: THERE HE BLEW UP THE
PLACE.
IT IS IN TATTERS.
>> Brian: IF THEY DON'T USE IT
IS IS TO THEIR ADVANTAGE.
>> Judge Jeanine: I HAVE TO
TELL YOU ONE MORE THING, ONE OF
TWITTER'S LARGER SHAREHOLDERS,
HE IS TRYING TO MAKE AN OFFER TO
BUY IT BECAUSE HE IS AND
BELIEVES MUSK WITH ELECTRIC CARS
IS UNDERCUT HOW GNOMIC
UNDERCUTTING THE POWER OF BODY
SOIL.
THERE ARE SO MANY LEVELS OF
THIS.
>> Greg: UNIT WITH THE
DEADLINE IS FOR THE DEAL?
>> WHAT IS IT?
4/20.
>> CAN I BRING UP ONE MORE
THING?
THE BEST SENSE OF HUMOR, HEY,
ELON IF YOU BUY THIS THING CAN
YOU GET RID OF MY COMBINE
PHOTOS?
THIS IS THE MUSCLE DON